for Saudis this might not be new news
but for most of the world this is the
story about Saudi women that is never
told saturated about just camels and a
desert really are progressive we're
normal people just like any other
country
[Music]
I found you guys
[Music]
everybody thinks that we're too
close-minded we there's no progression
in the country at all and we have oil
tanks sitting in our homes but it's not
the case at all this is a liberal
perspective to balance it out yeah yeah
but it's impossible to yeah it's just
not gonna happen camera in there so just
to be fair there are many narratives
here
so like 10% things like you
but I cannot count Iran really probably
oh yeah around but what about in Jeddah
yeah Jenna would have a higher rate
compared to other regions
probably Jetta and eastern region I
think that's what makes Jetta the most
progressive and
most liberal one because it's a melting
pot of so many different cultures here
because of Mecca and Medina a lot of
people from all around the world all the
Muslims from all around the world pass
by Jeddah it's the gateway when they go
for pilgrimage and a lot of them to stay
back and live here
have the next generations here and that
I think that makes a huge impact on how
progressive and liberal this part of the
country is she's the driving mate yeah
like that was like 10 years ago like oh
man are gonna drive the woman are here
more than 10 years they keep saying that
but it never happened and then like out
of nowhere unexpected okay you're a lot
to driver like everything cinema was not
everything happened at once which is
great yeah
but then the street nobody knows we
don't know it's like yeah so it's like
are these anxious times anywhere else we
have the same problems
exactly I don't have time to juggle
between my job on my kids
but number one academic really you're an
entrepreneur yeah what are you doing
I do its registration plaque one
weddings babies birthdays graduations if
there isn't any online registries
without me so personally by advantage in
weddings are massive deal yeah huge the
biggest problem I'm saying that I want
the world to know that we're not to be
bored or strictly religious or not open
to change I want people to know that we
do have great education an amazing
community and great society no not to
the individuals themselves not the
citizens or maybe put politics yes but
individuals themselves no not really
what do you think the West
[Music]
family values I don't know we're very
very family-oriented community to the
fact that a lot of the houses we live
with our grandparents don't we visit our
family two or three times a week we do
care about the decisions honestly and
their opinions I mean not disability
vibes co-working space here in Jeddah
Saudi Arabia and what is very cool about
here is something completely unexpected
at least to me which is happening female
entrepreneur seen a lot of people would
think that there's not a lot of female
pairs here however technically we're
ruining everything guess it because then
rather than a females as they might say
it's a few educated female you're
educating a whole community so there's a
lot of female entrepreneurs here and if
you want to introduce it to couple do
you find yourself having you explain
Saudi say when you're in the US or in
Europe sometimes yes cuz not a lot of
people are educated which I don't I
don't blame them about
with media and everything but a lot of
times I have to explain to them that
it's a bit different we don't we're not
as whatever Hollywood show to you we're
totally different than that not all of
us think that way so it's very different
the same thing with the u.s. a lot of
people for example when they see the
president they think everyone was like
what yeah yeah so that's why that like a
lot of people should not judge by what
they see in the media because it's
totally different than going there are
speaking someone speaking to someone
who's there the local banks are
currently working together to create
boot camps for either female
entrepreneurs or any type of
entrepreneur to kind of help them start
their idea help them forth funding it
and helping them with everything like
that
so the support wise there's always
support to guarantee don't mind so for
example now there's a director that's
completely run by a female entrepreneur
it's this business yes Taylor sure I
think the CEO just passed by business
yes it is okay what are you doing so
we're a graphic design firm we do
everything graphic designer related
social media photography videography
branding core identities campaign social
media campaigns whoops
designs development all-female sale in
you the co-founder yeah it's going great
it's been over a year now so yeah yeah
you got a through the year yes and we're
actually expanding we started at a small
in the smaller office downstairs and
then we upgraded up here what's behind
the decisions to have only females
honestly um we are a team of feminists
positive feminists so we just wanted to
like basically con to contradict the the
norm but to contradict the norm women
especially in our society and everything
are known to be us you know submissive
and we do I mean that we'll always have
some sort of male figure but we kind of
wanted to just go again side and
a different point so we never noticed
that we don't have an actual like
something or a symbol that we can wear
that represents us as Muslims or
represents us as as Arabs in general
something like the cross or something
for like that's that's an example so
what they did is they basically took
different religious aspects from our
culture or different culture things and
they turned it into jewelry so people
could wear what are you working on so my
company's her workshop and basically we
create jewelry that's inspired by
culture Arabic and spirituality it's
basically a sound wave of a Quranic
verse that's meant for protection of
loved ones
lemmy's here that's doing a marketing
he's helping us with social media and
strategies we have suffered as well
she's helping us with supply chain and
vendor management so we started to
actually in Canada and move back to
Saudi because we had a bigger client
base here people here spend more in
terms of accessories and things that
they like in terms of the culture and
spiritual aspect then people do in North
America so your employees here took a
little risk because they didn't go the
traditional route they didn't get a
government job or work for a bank or
something yeah they believed in you
they believed in ethanol do believe in
themselves that they can actually help
them and make this become a bigger thing
that itself already have which is a
skincare company it's run for they buy a
lovely Saudi woman whose background is
legal by the way she's a lawyer
so I'm gonna leave it up to her so what
is this all about well it's an
authentically organic and natural
skincare it's not common I would say
most people blindly put whatever and I
should including myself
I put sunscreen whatever and that's the
problem it's it's honestly in the long
run that you see those effects it's not
something that happens instantly but
it's in the long run where you find
yourself getting these my passion for
aromatherapy started at the younger age
and I thought now is the time now is the
time to side the what again well it
comes with every entrepreneur that's one
of the conditions I guess so yes that's
the jump I took
[Music]
it's very similar to meditating because
when you're praying and you're saying
that I'll put on addresses you're you
you're going to this weird state that
you feels just so common that even if
you're very angry or if you're very
upset it really helps you
because most of the time when you're
stressed some time just taking a deep
breath and connecting to God really nice
and just we were just talking about the
other day we have 50% of our startups of
like our 10 startups which are either
co-founded or founded by women you know
and that's an amazing thing in you'd
think that but actually in the Middle
East um there is more funding that's
available to tech startups that are run
by women as in a global percentage as
opposed to the rest of the world and
there are more tech female founders um
like higher percentage than the rest of
the world which is a very interesting
statistics because so I think a lot of
things is basically like a lot of the
younger generation they are becoming
more empowered and for them it is a
desire to prove themselves right it's
really inspiring that everyone now is
like looking for their own business and
they want to create their own brands or
something something they're passionate
about it's even more better it's more
freedoms like they can do their own
thing without any like culture and
limits or governmental limits or
anything they're all supportive of
supporting this this matter
that's my heart attacks like people are
connecting a lot of prom with co-working
spaces is people are in their own zone
and you guys really do a good job
bringing it together thank you thank you
so much that's it I think in five been
by my side it's a bird
you